henry cavill is apparently not one to
mince words in a recent interview with
Men's Health the actor and erstwhile
Superman was asked about the three films
in which he filled out Kyle's famous
cape in responding he admitted to
feeling exactly like the rest of us do
about Justice League a DC movie universe
has been on a roll for the last couple
years or so 2017 s1 the woman was a
critical and box-office hit and more
recently last year's Aquaman and this
year's Joker have both cleared the
billion-dollar mark of the worldwide
box-office while satisfying the fandom
prior to their successes though the road
was quite a bit rocky ER and that rocky
stretch included the entirety of cavalls
tenure as big blue so far anyway 2013's
might have steals that off the franchise
and while it performed respectively it
divided fans many of whom were
unprepared for writer David s Goyer and
director Zack Snyder's exceedingly dark
vision of the last Son of Krypton stale
that flick was followed by 2016 s Batman
vs. Superman dawn of Justice a film
which probably should have broken every
box office record in existence due to
its pairing of the two comic book icons
on screen for the first time the flick
did clear eight hundred and seventy
million dollars globally but critics
were generally not impressed and it
divided audiences even more sharply
industry observers noted that the
failure of a movie with both Batman and
Superman in his title to make over a
billion dollars was troubling 2016
Suicide Squad which endure amid
production course correction aimed
injecting a bit more levity continued
the trend of earning respectable box
office numbers while getting mostly
trashed by critics and then came 2017 s
Justice League oh boy
his back a team-up film reunited Ben
Affleck's Batman and gal gadot as Wonder
Woman with cavil Superman and also
introduced Jason Momoa as Aquaman
Ezra Miller's the flash and Rey fish's
cyborg despite production troubles it
was a film that should have had DC fans
over the moon with excitement it did not
Justice League struggled to a 677
million dollars worldwide gross the
worst performance for a DC movie
universe film of thus far and for the
reason why look no further than cavils
assessment of his three outings as soups
on Man of Steel he said a great starting
point if I were to go back I don't think
I'd change anything I'm dawn of Justice
he opined very much a Batman movie and I
think that realm of darkness is great
for a Batman movie finally on Justice
League he admitted that quote it didn't
work there's no denying that Justice
League indeed didn't work although
things may have turned out differently
had Snyder not handed over the reins to
just Whedon following a family tragedy
by all accounts the film turned in by
Whedon was a very very different one
from that which would have been fielded
by Snyder so much so that in recent
years since Justice League's release
fans have been lobbying hard for studio
Warner Brothers to release Snyder's Kurt
of the film which the director has said
would need only a few CGI tweaks to
complete he is hoping a man on you used
to say that hope is like a car keys easy
to lose we could dig around the movies
failure though has contributed said to
the public perception that Kaval may
indeed be done playing Superman his dawn
of Justice co-star Affleck has hung up
Batman's cape and cowl for good making
way for a different younger iteration of
the Caped Crusader to be portrayed by
Robert Pattinson invited director Matt
Reeves forthcoming the Batman well no
comparable Superman project has yet been
announced it seems like just a matter of
time before big blue gets or reboot
treatments as well the perception that
cavil is through was further bolstered
by his non cameo at the end of this
year's Shazam in which Supes showed up
to have a bite of lunch with a titular
hero and was portrayed by a stand-in
shown only from the neck down
for the record though cavil only failed
to a priceless role because of
scheduling conflicts with Mission
Impossible fallouts answer
the star salad it may not be as dumb as
Superman as everyone seems to think he
is the actor said the cape is still in
the closet it's still mine I'm not just
going to sit quietly in the dark as all
this stuff is going on I've not given up
the role there's a lot I have to give
for Superman yet a lot of storytelling
to do a lots of real true deaths to the
honesty of the character I want to get
into I want to reflect the comic books
that's important to me there's a lot of
justice to be done for Superman that is
far far more than cover that's sad to
say on the subject in the last couple of
years if we're being honest we've always
felt like his version of Supes got the
short end of the stick and his obvious
sense of ownership over the role has us
pretty much convinced that he should be
given a chance to flesh out the
character in a way those previous
appearances didn't quite allow for so
does cavil have an actual status for us
on the future of his version of Superman
according to cavil quote the statuses
you'll see check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos buy your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]